is being 17 right yeah yeah but 17 bro
what do you mean 17 I was Moody bro no
more introverted moody I play chess I
did all kinds of [ __ ] bro did you really
yeah do you don't seem like that can i
guys my stepdad bro oh it's Coco
actually who's Coco oh yeah yeah yeah
Coco yo Joey it's Bobby Lee dude we were
he's on my podcast right now bro he was
doing my podcast right now and now
you're we're looking beautiful you're a
guest star right now but Joey will you
do my podcast what are you gonna do my
podcast yeah you're doing it tonight
you're gonna be in soon okay bro I'm
gonna call you all right love you buddy
all right all right all right you too
Joe thanks for checking in he's a best
man it'll call me like once every couple
weeks in this check-in see how I'm doing
yeah why I don't know that's a yes nice
guy like you said man it's like you know
people doing those nice things man it
reminds me sometimes if I was showing
this young dude on and I'll hit him up
and be like you were hilarious or
something you know yeah or just
something that's gonna boost his spirits
yeah but yeah I don't know maybe I'm
being a little bit rude to the 17 year
old you know I just that's actually good
advice to every single teenager and I
wish someone had said that to me when I
was 17 because I really was a little bit
too full of myself not even in the sense
that I was actually full of myself I was
just thinking of myself and everything
everything that pertained only to me how
the world exists and how it pertains to
me only not the other way around and
that's ya didn't service me later and I
got stuck in that so yeah it's a tough
thing to get stuck in I was lost man
where are you yeah I got sober when I
was 17 bro
burro my first time sober was 17 - and I
stayed sober until I was 30 but dude I
was lost from and when you went out at
30 how long did you go out there for
couple years man thankful to him real
painful Joey Diaz I almost killed a
couple times as he used to like I used
to bring [ __ ] up a [ __ ] suitcase
full of pills ha and Joey Diaz was the
first one I was handed to yeah yeah and
then he would like take like my pills
and then like he would take a pillow and
then go to the bathtub and then lay the
you know pillow in the bathtub put the
shower on take my pills and just fall
asleep cause I thought he was gonna die
yeah you know that's Vietnam right there
that's making your own Vietnam bro with
all that moisture so what's her name man
Oh Katherine Katherine this is good luck
[Music]